what was your reaction to the sen
sentencing today of allison mack
i mean initially i was pretty shocked
because this has
taken years and it was sort of surreal
that it actually happened so
quickly i was expecting to you know be
waiting anxiously pacing around my mom's
house all day long
and it happened within a matter of hours
and so that was shocking
and i i'm still kind of like
processing it all to be honest yeah
have you had a chance to talk to your
mom about it yes i have
and um and we're both actually really
like please is not the right word but
validated by the
and we both have a lot of trust in this
judge
and he is very wise and he has set an
incredible standard
by giving keith renee 120 years in
prison and that's his scale
ultimately in my mind this is all
because of the wrong doings that keith
renery has done
yeah so allison's punishment
is an effect of that and and virtue is
too
and so i think that it's a really it's
setting a standard
that really abuse is not going to be
tolerated and it is not going to be
allowed
and that really feels good to me you
know
today um well allison put out a
statement
apologizing do you accept that apology
i do i don't have any reason to not
accept her apology
ultimately the apology is for her and
her
own well-being moving forward and
whatever she needs to resolve in herself
it does not change the past for me it
really just informs me about her and
where she's at in her own healing
process
it it made me feel safer to know that
she has
renounced herself of keith renery and
she doesn't believe him anymore
so that i actually thought was a huge
victory in her own healing
and for her future what do you think is
next for her and um
what message would you send to allison
today i just don't know
exactly where she is at in her own
healing journey
but i do know that it takes an enormous
amount of bravery
and the ability to admit that you're
wrong
and that you are fooled and that you
hurt other people that's very hard
and so i know that that was a really
challenging part for me to accept
everything
that i had participated in the good the
bad and the ugly and so
i think for her it's gonna be a hard
journey to regain
her empathy and her ability to be
a human being in society what would you
say to her today if you could speak to
her
she feels really simple but i just wish
her well because
i don't um have any interest in having
any kind of relationship with her at all
my life but i don't wish her
any ill will it's not necessary i don't
need to do that
i i'm moving on and i certainly hope
that she does
you mentioned that she has now kind of
admitted and come to the hard
realization that she played a part in
this but do you think she was also a
victim in any way
i do i think she was absolutely a victim
of keith rainery and i really do think
that the judge acknowledged that as well
in her sentencing i mean look look at
the difference between
what keith renery was sentenced and what
she was sentenced
it's very clear to me that they're on a
very different although
similar crimes yeah and keith had zero
remorse when he was sentenced
he basically was like i don't i did what
i basically called us all liars so it
was like
that is a human being that is unsafe to
be
in society and that is why he is where
he is
he is someone that was able to
rehabilitate himself and i do believe
and i really did
pray that alison would be able to do
that for herself irrespective if i
ever was going to relate with her again
i hoped that she would find herself
again
do you do you feel like today wraps up
this chapter
in your life i do i feel like this was
an enormous amount of pleasure for me
and i'm really ready to move on
from nexium and i mean i'll continue to
do my
work and my activism and
that i think are impossible to know and
to be aware of
but i am very much ready to put nexium
behind me
[Music]
do you think this could be turned into a
movie one day
[Laughter]
i mean if anyone's interested in
watching maybe
but i it has been a wild ride
and a very strange strange journey and
maybe it could be a film um but
i don't know if that's the best way for
people to understand
and to become aware and to be educated
so i think that there's
a lot of different ways that we could
use this
information to teach people inform the
people who might not know about these
types of predators and groups